what's going on guys today i was meant
to be doing a breakdown for
micro academia chapter 289
but something said by toga in that
chapter
inspired me to make a theory video
instead this theory came to me whilst i
was doing the live stream yesterday on
twitch
but yeah let's just get into this theory
and spoiler warning for those of you who
do not read the manga and don't want to
know spoilers after season 4.
okay so we all know that twice died
earlier on in the war
arc after being killed by hawks however
back in chapter 228 skeptic mentioned
how twice's ability
could be used to revive redestro in case
he were to die
and that same principle is still true
yes
the real twice is dead and as we saw
when he died
all of his clones died with him so he
has no active clones out there in the
world
but there is still a way to bring him
back the myvlan academia arc
gave us a proper insight into how toga
thinks
and her way of thinking was reiterated
again in chapter 289
to be specific when toga admires someone
she has an uncontrollable urge to become
them
which is why she often tries to get the
blood of people she likes
this was demonstrated in her early
childhood when she consumed the blood of
a bird that she thought was cute
and then later as a schoolgirl she drank
the blood of her classmate
who looks almost identical to deku by
the way
for toga blood and admiration are two
things that go hand in hand
which is exactly the reason why twice
will return
as of making this video the people she
admires most in the series
are probably deku ochako maybe mr
compress
and definitely twice throughout all her
time with the league of villains
twice was the person she was closest to
and she even referred to him
as like her precious big brother
following toga's own logic of how she
desires the blood of the people she
admires
i'd say there is no other character in
the series who toga is
more likely to have a storage of blood
from than twice
not only did she admire him but they
spent a large amount of time together
and of course you know if she asked him
of course he'd willingly give up any
blood that she asked for
this is where things get interesting
because in my vlog in academia we saw
that in certain circumstances together
can use the quirks of people she turns
into
she was able to use ochako's gravity
quirk and knew
how to use it because she'd seen ochako
use it before
similarly toga has seen twice's quirk in
action
countless times throughout the series
and knows its strengths and weaknesses
she was also standing right next to him
during the overhaul arc
when twice explained his quirk in
incredible detail
so if she was to try and use his quirk
it's fair to say that she would know
what she was doing in the latest chapter
toga specifically stated that drinking
the blood of someone she loves
gives her their quirk as well this was a
nice confirmation for harakoshi to
include
because i know some people thought that
toga was only able to use achako's quirk
because it was like a life or death
situation but no
i mean this wording right here from
harakoshi is basically telling us that
if toga admires a person enough
she can use their quirk therefore based
on everything i just said
at some point in the future toga can
consume whatever blood she has left of
twice
and use that to turn herself into him
due to her understanding of his quirk
and her extensive knowledge of twice
himself having spent a ton of time with
him
she almost certainly has enough data to
create a double of twice
thanks to chapter 240 we know for a fact
that every double created by twice's
quirk
also has the blood of the original
person
in that previous chapter we got
confirmation that twice
took the blood from one of toga's clones
and then gave it to the real toga to
save her life
so yeah like i said it means that clones
have blood
as a result once toga creates a double
of twice
she can take as much blood as she needs
from that double
and create an endless cycle in which she
can turn into twice
create doubles of him which then can
create doubles even more doubles of him
and then you know she can take blood
from those doubles and you know turn
herself back into twice
again and then it just can he continues
on and on and on basically forever
for argument's sake let's just say that
toga didn't have any of twice's blood
they can still go back to the mansion
and just get his body you know
it's presumably still there i don't
think anyone would have stolen it
uh if anyone was gonna do that it would
have been hawks and he's he's long gone
so if they think of this idea then they
can just go back to the mansion
and get his body and take whatever
little drop of blood they can find
so that toga can turn into him just
briefly and then create a double which
can then obviously
everything just starts from there one
interesting detail about twice's quirk
is that the clones he creates are simply
a version of a person
from the last time he saw them if we
apply that rule to toga
then the twice that she would be able to
create would be how twice looked the
last time she saw him
now the last time she really saw the the
actual twice
happened totally off screen it was
before the war began and it
likely would have been in the paranormal
liberation front mansion but like i said
we never saw
it with that said that's my theory on
how toga can turn
into twice and then use his quirk to
create more twices
which you know in turn they can create
more spices and just create an army of
twices
so his spirit will live on through toga
potentially
be sure to follow me on twitch for
reactions to the latest chapters
and until the next video peace out